موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم منظمه قوه واحزاب
معارضه ومنظمات مدنيه مظاهرات وتحركات
احتجاجيه رفضا لما تسميه تفرد الرئيس قيس
سعيد بالسلطه وتهديد الحقوق والحريات
وانتهاك استقلال القضاء وعبرت هذه القوه
عن رفضها للاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي
اتخذها الرئيس التونسي والمسار السياسي
الحالي الذي يقوده وتزامنت هذه الاحتجاجات
مع ذكر الثوره التونسيه التي تحل في ظل
الانقسام السياسي وازمه الاقتصاديه
متفاقمه
وقال رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطني احمد نجيب
الشابي للجزيره ان تونس في حاجه ماسه الى
قياده جديده عبر عمليه انتخابيه للخروج من
ازمتها الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الراهنه
واكد الشاب انه لم يعد في وسعر رئيس سعيد
ان يقدم شيئا بعد ما فشل في اداره الشؤون
اليوميه للمواطنين حسب تعبيره وفي تصريح
اذاعشاب بالاتحاد العام التونسيه للشغل
الى الخروج من سقف الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو والى ان لا يبقى سجينا لصراعات
الماضيه
وكان رئيس التونسي قيس سعيد قد قال ان
بلاده في حاله حرب مع الفساد ومع من وصفهم
بالخونه والعملاء وخلال اجتماعه باعضاء
اللجنه الوطنيه للصلح الجزائي دعى سعيد
الى اعاده الاموال المنهوبه للشعب ومحاسبه
كل من اذنب في حق التونسيين وفقا تعبره
القوه الروسيه هجمات البنيه التحتيه في
انحاء اوكرانيا وقال حاكم مقاطعه جنيبرو
شرقي اوكرانيا ان قصر الروسيه لسادف
المدينه اسفر عن مقتل تسعه اشخاص وجرح
اكثر من 60 اخرين
اعلن مكتب رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي
سوناك عن اعتزام الحكومه تسليما اربعه 10
دبابه من طراز شالنجر 2 الى اوكرانيا خلال
الاسابيع المقبله وكان سونا قد وعد الرئيس
الاوكرانيه فلودو ميرسي لنسكي في اتصالي
هاتفا بعزم المملكه المتحده رساله دبابات
من نوع تشالنجر 2 الى اوكرانيا لمساعدتها
في مواجهه حرب روسيا عليها وتمارس السلطات
الاوكرانيه ضغوطا كبيره على الحكومه
الالمانيه لمدها ب دبابات حديثه
قال الناطق باسم رئاسه التركيه ابراهيم
قال ان تركيا ترغب في تشجيع على الاعلان
عن وقف المحدود لاطلاق النار بين كل من
روسيا واوكرانيا كخطوه الاحترازيه في حال
عدم النجاح في التوصل الى اتفاقيه سلام
شامل بين الطرفين
اعلن القضاء الايراني اعدام علي رضا اكبر
مساعدي وزير الدفاع السابق بتهمه التجسس
لصالح الاستخبارات البريطانيه والعمل ضد
امن الدوله في الداخل وخارج البلاد وفق
تعبيره وكانت الاستخبارات الايرانيه
واعلنت في وقت سابق ان علي رضا اكبر كان
يتجسس على المراكز الحساسه والاستراتيجيه
الايراني واعتقل قبل ثلاث سنوات بعد عمليه
طويله ومعقده
من جانبه اعلن وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
فرض عقوبات على النائب العام الايراني
بريطانيا من اعدام المواطن البريطاني
الايراني علي رضا اكبر بدوره عبر الرئيس
الوزراء البريطاني سوناك عن صدمته لاعدام
علي رضا اكبر ووصف في تغريده العدامه بانه
عمل قاس وجبان نفذه نظام همجي لا يحترم
حقوق الانسان
ختام الموجز في امان الله